la fibre optique on en parle beaucoup
mais peu l'utilise encore pour cause sur
le département son déploiement a été
lancé en 2010 par Orange et SFR pour
couvrir d'ici 2020 une centaine de
communes ce qui représente pour vous
donner quelques repères 83 % des
logement qui seront donc déployés par
l'initiative privée dans le département
la fibre optique a été déployée sur le
secteur de Saint-Germain h et des
boucles de scèes plaisir fait partie des
20 premières communes fibrées 50 % des
logements peuvent potentiellement y
accéder on a trois critères on va dire
il y a un critère de de de densité un
critère technique en fonction des
équipements des centraux téléphonique et
puis on va en priorité dans des communes
dans des quartiers de communes où le
réseau ADSL apporte un débit le plus
faible enfin le plus faible le
déploiement de la fibre sur la ville de
Plaisir devrait s'achever d'ici
2015-27 l'ensemble des habitants et des
entreprises pourront profiter d'un
réseau 10 à 20 fois plus rapide que la
dsl de quoi intéresser ceux qui veulent
utiliser de nouveaux services comme la
télé en 3D télécharger ou envoyer des
fichiers très lourds un défi stratégique
pour les communes qui espèrent ainsi
attirer des entreprises à fortes demande
technologique économique pour les
opérateurs qui investissent de Lourdes
sommes 2 milliards d'euros rien que pour
Orange pour l'ensemble du
territoire